one great question i got asked about
many worlds is if many worlds is true
and every time you do a measurement you
and everything else that was measured um
get split into two copies of yourself
essentially then
how on earth is energy being conserved
the thing is this is a problem not just
in many worlds but in quantum mechanics
in general and it just is sort of like
writ large by many worlds because the
kind of things that are going into
superposition are much much larger like
yourself so you obviously have much more
mass than an electron but it's just as
egregious if an electron was to split
into two and therefore make two copies
of itself doubling its mass that's also
not energy conserved in this video i'm
going to talk about how i think about
this problem but i just want to put it
out there that i think other physicists
have different solutions to this um and
some people actually just don't seem to
really think it's a problem at all so
i'm just going to explain what my
opinion on this is like i said earlier
it's just as egregious if an electron
splits into two copies of itself as if a
human did so
right now we're going to take as our
example something that's a little bit
more in the middle and it's a tardigrade
you may have heard of these little
creatures they have this like weird hole
in their face i don't know the reason
why i'm using tardigrades as examples is
because they are the largest
multicellular organism that has been put
into quantum superposition they're not
that small they're actually kind of big
uh like they're kind of on the order of
about one millimeter it's honestly like
pretty big so i think it was pretty
surprising that something like this
could be put into a superposition but
apparently it can
we're going to use these as our example
because they're small but they're not
that small and real experiments with
them have been done so all of this is
feasible whether you believe in many
worlds or just regular quantum mechanics
the experiment that we're going to do
with our poor little tardigrade is to
throw it at a wall
where the wall has
two openings that are big enough for the
tardigrade to go through and the
question is which of these two slits did
the tardigrade go through the actual
experiment that they did with these
things uh was actually a lot more
impressive than this double slit setup
it was this like entangling operation
which is really really cool but i think
that this one's easier to think about
and given the other one was possible i
think this one is also feasible but what
do i know
anyway if the creature was to go through
this
slit here then we
will say that it is in the state up
because it went through the up slit
whereas if it were to have instead gone
through this one then we'll say that it
was in the down slit the thing with
quantum mechanics is that if you do it
right you should be able to get a
superposition of the object going
through both of these at the same time
in that case we could say that the
object was in a superposition
of having gone through both
so far in these videos i've been
dropping off the factors but i'm just
actually going to put these here for a
second because i think it's actually a
little bit relevant to this discussion
so here the two coefficients are equal
which means that this split into two
equal parts now what's going on here if
the target is going through both of
these things like what's happening to it
i mean it can't be splitting into two
it's an it's an object that's alive like
if you split it into two then it's not
gonna be uh like a living creature at
the end of this experiment so
does that mean that there's two copies
of it that's what this might suggest and
uh yeah i have heard some physicists
talk about this in a way where like they
kind of imply that that's what they
believe that there really is like two
different worlds one where the
tardigrade goes through the up slit and
one where it goes through the down slit
and it's okay energy is sort of
conserved anyway because when you think
about the total energy you just have to
like sort of weight the energies by the
factors and then you know there's half
of the weight here half of the weight
here and so then the total mass is like
weighted by those factors
i think that's a kind of weasley way to
get out of this i mean if there are
literally two versions of this thing
then there should be twice the mass i i
don't feel like you can just kind of get
around it by saying well we're just
going to count the mass in different
ways depending on these coefficients
here's my current view on things
this wave function which i'm just going
to call
psi
which is like in quantum mechanics the
standard way of how you keep track of
the state of an object my solution is
that this wave function isn't the object
it's the state of the object
what does that mean
so i guess in this example it would mean
that our body here exists and is real
and
has mass
but this wave function
is describing the state of that object
the state of that object currently is
the state of both having gone through
the top slit and the bottom slit but
there's still only one of that object
and so i guess this is like a kind of
funny distinction between these two
things so this like object is real the
wave function is like the thing that's
talking about the possible states that
that object could be in but i think this
gets even weirder when you start looking
at other examples suppose that we have
this
beautifully illustrated uranium atom
i don't know what's going on here anyway
uranium can decay into a bunch of other
things
one possibility is for it to decay into
thorium and
helium
quantum mechanically it is in a
superposition of both having not decayed
and decayed that means the state of the
uranium
is that it is uranium or it's thorium
plus alpha particle but going back to
what i was saying earlier about like the
object being the real thing and the wave
function being just the state of that
thing
that doesn't quite work here because you
can't just say oh the uranium is the
real thing because one of the states is
for the uranium to not even be uranium
anymore and so what you really should
say is like the constituent parts of the
uranium are the real thing or perhaps
like even better is instead of saying
it's the uranium you should say
it's the
energy that could be uranium but could
be thorium plus helium
and so it's the energy that's in a
superposition of doing various things
and so then the thing that's real in
this view is just like the energy of all
objects and then
uh that energy is in a superposition of
like possibilities it's its state is in
various uh configurations um some of
those configurations are like certain
types of particles but the energy
is the only real thing um
thinking about that
honestly makes me kind of upset
uh
so
i think i'm just going to end this video
here thanks for your question